going actually 30 years 38 years ago
maybe to 1981 when you were taking a
portrait session with a special person
named Toni Morrison can you take us back
to that day what do you remember Toni
Morrison walked into my studio in
February 1981 I was 29 I was sort of
starting my career as a photographer she
was smoking a pipe and I remember you
know someone asked me recently what do
you remember from that I remember her
confidence and as a photographer you
kind of read people and you can sense if
they're nervous and she did she was
perfectly fine and if she was cool and
that was the beginning of our friendship
it continued I became kind of
photographer of choice for her we did
book jackets together and press pictures
and later she inspired a whole series I
did starting with the blacklist on
identity and was really I think a
privilege just to be her friend of all
this time just used photographed when do
you realize that Toni Morrison needed a
documentary I think around the time of
the blacklist when we did I did a there
were 23 people in that film and I
thought each one of them deserved a
documentary but if I were to do the
first one it would be Toni Morrison and
you know at a certain point a few years
ago I just felt she was in her early 80s
and I thought it's now or never if I'm
really gonna do this
and Toni is a very private person she
does not authorize biographies she
bowknot she won't write an autobiography
and I asked her if she would consider it
and she did not say no and I knew that
was a yes and and it took a little time
to kind of figure out how I was going to
do this but you know she's 88 now can
you analyze for us a little bit this
very unique structure even the way you
photograph Toni versus the other people
the way you employ our
work still images and archival footage
how did that all come to you into this
amazing piece I was an art history major
at Columbia so I have a lot of love for
the art world and I knew a lot of the
artists I'd spent 20 years photographing
artists and I wanted to incorporate that
somehow into the film it's you don't
really see fine art paintings in
documentaries usually if you do this an
illustration of something but here I
wanted to kind of have it feel something
and it was also a way to bring in 24
african-american artists work into it
people who revered Tony loved Tony were
in you know very influenced by Tony I
also shot Tony direct to camera which I
had the the list films were direct to
camera and I loved that but I thought
here maybe I could have Tony tell the
story directed camera and everyone else
talks off camera and it was a way to
make her the center of it she's telling
her story and they're sort of secondary
talking about her you it worked but if
you if it didn't you know you're stuck
with it so it was a kind of a risky
thing to do because you not seen Docs
that do that but I felt that it was a
way to kind of give her agency in a
sense that it was her telling the story
she wanted to tell very intimately
before this break came to you what was
your idea of Tony Morrison
that's a good question because it's got
such depth to it I really can't I can't
put that in a particular I can't
capitalize that because she is such
she's such a force and her awareness of
that kind of presence so she's so
authentic and that's the thing that
really continues to be very important
for me in resonates with me but when
Timothy called
and said
Toni Morrison that's all I needed to
hear you know I knew that it was going
to be an incredible and powerful journey
creatively and I will say this that they
Timothy and his team you all gave me
incredible flexibility to to try
different textures I mean this this
score has so many different genres that
I love jazz vocals solo piano fiddle
upright bass and a lot of it was music
that had been tempted in terms of
textures you guys had placed a lot of
upright bass and so that was a good
point of departure but we all just you
know it's it's her work has an energy
field that's very very powerful and very
visceral and I think that as a creative
person if you can surrender or yield to
that then the work itself begins to it's
conversation and it begins to gestate it
begins to create itself and in trusting
that and having a group of people that
are in that synergy is really what
helped to create this this score for me
this song that closes the film was
composed and performed by you thank you
thank you so much that was another I
mean this was like I just want to take
them with me wherever I go can you you
guys be my yeah clone that was an
incredible gift because typically you
know the in title it's it's a song that
you can they could have licensed it or
had others created but I think we had
all been in this really very very
intense and an intimate process so again
it was just it was a creative choice
that I really really appreciate this
film has to do a lot about race in
America
what is your reflection about the
importance of this film and Toni
Morrison's not just in the past but in
the present and what is the optimistic
view that you can give us for the future
I'm not sure I can give an optimistic
view of the future will know that in
2020 you know I think the themes that
Tony started out with that they're part
of her life are as important today as
they were then they're even they
resonate more and more she is a kind of
figure that we all follow that you know
her ideas and her sense of justice and
her sense of humanity are so powerful
and and I think also so inspirational I
mean it's not just to African Americans
I think this is a person who speaks to
people all over the world so it's a it's
just such a rare person Toni Morrison I
feel that the issue of race at this time
is so charged because of the systemic
recycling of a narrative that absolutely
has to be addressed but beyond that
narrative what what I like to call
attention to is the belief system that
creates the narrative in the first place
we never we never really go into that we
we have a tendency to get very consumed
by the constructs which are which are
absolutely present so the beauty the
beauty about Toni and that last scene in
particular is that she she brought it
all home in talking about the essence of
humanity which is that in the unknown
between us is more of the known and more
of the shared and so from me I I sort of
I look to life that way and music is in
and of itself it's such an otherworldly
force it's such you know when you're
right when I'm writing the process for
me is extremely organic it's very
present and so I don't have any
room for second guessing that because
it's so precious so that's how I'm
informed we would like to thank you very
much for being with us tonight